however you want to say it all except
we're friends now we are going to be
enemies after this challenge guys I'm
here with Meghan tonjes ah you're doing
the no thumbs challenge which was
originally created by Rachel Ballinger
here on YouTube I've tweeted out asking
you guys for everyday activities that
would be more difficult to do if we
didn't have thumbs
correct so Jack Berger is gonna read out
a series of tweets we're gonna race to
try and get that challenge done without
our thumbs and the first person to get
to five will be the winner Megan was
saying before that she plays guitar so
she thinks she has like the strength and
dexterity and her fingers that's really
gonna help her out and I I don't I'm
hoping I'm long et like fingers so maybe
that'll be something adventage or it'll
be to your detriment cuz I got little
fingers so maybe I'll be able to like
yeah hold it down easy I'm doing this
motion and I know it's gonna get gifts
in this video Jack Barry hey master
extraordinaire everybody's favorite jack
this was the weirdest thing of dudes
ever done to me I will say that Jack
Barrios now since tape it up my hands
here I'm not too deep yeah I think it's
like too many two men and like it's way
too many then the friends should have as
a number between themselves and you move
your thumbs no I can but that one's in
good turn into a crustacean Gracie I'm
great
okay so Jack first challenge open a
bottle yeah feels good right yeah
weirdly cathartic back peel a banana
Negus new challenge can make it make
this not sexual okay to zero here we go
challenge open a bag of chips and eat
one banana you ready yeah okay write
your first name on a piece of paper 3 2
1 cut through that piece of paper with a
pair of scissors
Thank You chub how quickly you can get
it done and then help me out yeah you're
welcome
huh okay what is it four to one [ __ ]
okay let's do this
make a peanut butter and jelly sandwich
[Music]
floss I mean this is goals are getting
away oh my god oh my god oh my dentist
would be so proud of you not only was
this a challenge video it's also a
message about dental hygiene no more
excuses you can do it without your thumb
this is still a thing that exists well
making time just thank you so much for
being here I hope that you enjoyed this
challenge we're about to film a record
rather a full episode of not too deep so
make sure you go over to SoundCloud or
iTunes and listen to that full episode
and where can they find you across the
internet Meghan tonjes on everything
Jakub comm / Tanja Tanja's I don't know
got in a fight where they were both
yelling about having guns he was like he
was like I have a [ __ ] gat and she
was like I have a [ __ ] gat and I was
like I'm gonna go inside
[Music]